[موسيقى]
عوده الهدوء تدريجيا في البرازيل الرئيس
الحاليه وعد المخربين ويتتهم سلفه والاخير
يتبرد
[موسيقى]
تنديدا بعزم النظام اعدام متظاهرين
مصادر العربيه تكشف عن لقاء سريه في
الاردن برعايه الامريكيه بين قيادات في
الجيش الليبي وزعماء فصائل المسلحه
[موسيقى]
طبتم مطابقه اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره
اخباريه من العربيه
اعاده الهدوء تدريجيا الى البرازيل بعد
اقتحامات شهدتها المقرات الحكوميه
الرئيسيه ما دفع بالرئيس البرازيلي
اعلان تدخل الامنيا
حتى نهايه الشهر الحالي ووصف ديسيبا في
خطاب مثير مثير الشغب بانه
ومتعصبون وقال انهم سيعاقبون بقوات
القانون الكامله وكذلك
واضاف الرئيس البرازيلي ان عده خطابات
لبولا سونارو الرئيس السابق شجع تنصره على
الاقتحامات مشيرا الى ان برازيليا شهدت
قصورا امنيا
رئيس البرازيليه السابق جرير بول سونارو
رفض الاتهامات التي وجهها له خليفه
على حسابه على تويتر ان المظاهرات السلبيه
جزء من الديمقراطيه معتبرا اي اقتحام او
نهبل للمباني العامه تجاوزا
هاي شرطه البرازيليه التي اعتقلت المئات
من انصار بول سونارو اخ للتدريجيه مقرات
الكونجرس والمحكمه العليا والقصر الرئاسي
من من وصفتهم بموتيري الشغب واظهرت صور
متداوله تحطيما انصار بولسونارو لغرفه
لولا دا سيلفا في القصر الرئاسي وكذلك
تحطيم مكاتب البرلمانيين كما وقف متظاهرون
على مقاعد مجلس الشيوخ وطلب بعض انصار فول
سونارو خلال الاقتحامات بتدخل عسكري
لالغاء نتائج الانتخابات وهيقالتي لولدها
سيلفا بدوره قال وزير العدل والامن
العامينو قال ان ما وصفها بالمحاوله
العبديه لن تسود
في سياق ردود الفعل الدوليه قال الرئيس
الامريكي ان الوضع في برازيليا مشين وكان
واشنطن دانت اي محاوله لتقويه الديمقراطيه
في البرازيل وقال مستشار الامن القومي
الامريكي جاك سوليفان ان بلاده تدين اي
محاولات لتقويه الديمقراطيه في البرازيل
باريس اصدرت من جهتها بيانا عبرت فيه عن
ادانتها لممارسه العنف ضد مؤسسات
الديمقراطيه البرازيليه وعبر الرئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون عن دعمه للرئيس
المنتخب واحترام المؤسسات اما رئيس المجلس
الاوروبي شعر ميشيل فاعرب في تغريده له عن
ادانته المطلقه لاقتحام مقر السلطات
الرئيسيه في البرازيل
قالت مصادر اعلاميه ان قوات الامن
الايرانيه اطلقت النار على منتظاهرين في
محيطه سجن رجائي في مدينه كرج غربي
العاصمه طهران حيث تجمع العشرات من
المواطنين امام بوابه السجن تنديدا بعزم
النظام اعدام متظاهرين واظهرت مقاطع فيديو
من مدينه كرج تجمع عشرات المواطنين امام
بوابه السجن تضامنا مع المتظاهرين
المتظاهرين بروجري وجبادلو المهددين
بالاعدام واكد التقارير نقلهما الى
الزنزانه الانفراديه في سجن رجاء بمدينه
كرش تمهيدا لتنفيذ حكم الاعدام ضدهما
هشام
وكان المحتجون
يوم امس تحت عنوان يوم الانتقام وذلك ردا
على اعدام الشابين محمد مهدي كرمي ومحمد
حسيني بتهمه قتل عضو في الفسيج
يا ماما عليه نامي نافع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
على طلاب كليه الفنون الجميله
ومنعوهم من اقامه مراسم الذكرى السنويه
الثالثه رضايا اسقاط الطائره الاوكرانيه
هذا المشهد يتكرروا للعام الثالث على
التوالي يرفع اهالي ضحايا الطائره
الاوكرانيه التي اسقطها الحرس الثوري
الايراني صور احبائهم التي لم تبقى سوىها
الكارثيه انا وعائله الضحايا نطلب معرفه
لماذا ارتكبت هذه الكارثه ومن كان وراءها
انه من حقنا والقتله يجب محاكمتهم
ومعاقبتهم في المحاكم الدوليه وهذا مطلبنا
من العالم ومن النظام الايراني
الحكومه الكنديه وبالتزامن مع ذكر الثالثه
لاسقاط الطائره طلب الطهران باجراء تحكيم
وتورتكزات في طلب التحكيم على اتفاقيه
مونتريال التي تنظم تسويه الجرائم ضد
الطيران على انه اذا لم يتفق الطرفان خلال
سته اشهر ترفع القضيه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
167 مسافرا بريئا على متن الطائره القادمه
من ايران الى اوكرانيا
كانت عمده وبالتالي عليكم ان تعلن
وتعترفوا بان كل الحرس الثوري الايراني
منظمه ارهابيه واذا لم تتعاون معكم ايران
في القضيه يجب ان تتحول الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
هل الضحيه تجمعوا امام مبنى منظمه الطيران
المدني الدولي في مونتريال مطالبين بعدم
الوثوق بايران وتحويل القضيه الى المحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه
اختلفت مراسم ذكرى سقوط الطائره هذا العام
لانها تزامنت مع احتجاجات تشهدها مدن
ايرانيه عده ارتفعت فيها اصوات المحتاجين
لاسر الضحايا ومطالبين بمحاسبه متورطين
وعلى راسهم خمنائي رفع السعد العربي
[موسيقى]
نفى الجيش الاوكراني ما قالته موسكو عن
مقتل 600 من جنوده في قصف الروسيه على
كرامه تريسكا شرقي البلاد وقال متحدث باسم
القياده الشرقيه للجيش الاوكرانيه ان
القوات الروسيه ليس لديها القدره على شان
ضربه شديده الدقه منجدا بما وصفه بالعمليه
الاعلاميه الروسيه في مواجهه النجاحات
الاوكرانيه على حد تعبيره
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تعزيز قواتها
في منطقه ايزابولوجيا ولوجاز تحسب لهجوم
الاخراني محتمل ومحاولتي تضييق الخناقه
على القوات الاوكرانيه في محيطه بخموط
للسيطره الكامله او على كامليسك
روسيا تعزيز دفاعاتها في منطقتي زاكوريجيا
وروجانيسك اوكرانيا تحسبا لهجوم ربما
ستشنه القوات الاوكرانيه قريبا وفقا
لتقرير الاستخبارات بريطانيا التقرير
البريطاني رجح ان تحقق القوات الاوكرانيه
تقدما كبيرا في زوريجيا سيشكل تحديا للجسر
البري الروسي الذي يربط منطقه روستوف
الروسيه وشبه جزيره القرم اما في مدينه
بخمود فان المعارك تحتدمه هناك بالاضافه
الى وسط سوريدار بمقاطعه حيث يتواصلوا
القصف الروسي لدفع الجيش الاوكراني على
الانسحاب منها الى بق محمود
وتراهن روسي على استراتيجيه ذات محورين
اولهما تكثيف قوه النيران ومن الصواريخ
البحريه بعد الدفع بقطع حديثه مثبت عليها
صواريخ سيركون خلال الايام الماضيه
والمحور الثاني تضييق الخناق على القوات
الاوكرانيه في محيط بخمه اهم المعارك
الحاليه لسيطره على كامل دونيتسك في
المقابل يقول تقرير حديث لمركز دراسه
الحرب الامريكيه ان المكاسب الروسيه في
سوليدار لا تنظر بتطويق
لان الامر يتعلق بضروره السيطره على اثنين
من الطرق السريعه بطول 13 كيلو مترا بينما
تتقدم القوات الروسيه بصعوبه
اذن ذكركم بهذا الخبر العاجل المحكمه
العليا البرازيليه تنتهي محاكم البرازيليا
بارتكاب اخطاء سهله اقتحامه المطار
الحكوميه
نكمل هذه النشره اكدت وزاره الدفاع في
بيلاروسيا ان موسكو ومانسيكا كثافه
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بناء على ما
اكتسبت روسيا من خبره في القتال في
اوكرانيا مع التركيز على ما وصفوه بحرب
المدن وقالت وزاره الدفاع انها عزت
تعاونها مع نظيرتها الروسيه
حيث تخططان لاجراء تدريبات جويه مشتركه
واشارت الى ان تدريبات على حرب المدن تحضر
باهتمام خاص في هذه المناورات وياتي
التعاون والعسكري المكثف بين البلدين
الحليفيين
في اوكرانيا والغرب بان موسكو قد تستغله
من سته منصه انطلاق لشان هجوم جديد على
اوكرانيا من جهه الشمال
اعلن يا وزير الاقتصاد الالماني روبرت
هابيك ان برلين لا يمكنها استبعاد تسليم
دبابات من طرازي ليوبارد الى اوكرانيا
وتاتي التصريحات الوزير الالماني بعد
يومين من اعلان برلين رقبتها في تسليم نحو
40 مركبه مشات قتاليه من طراز ماردير الى
اوكرانيا قبل نهايته مارس
هذه النشره مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
سبايدر مان يصل الى المكسيك في اول زياره
الرسميه له حضور قمه لقاده امريكا
الشماليه
حياكم الله
افادت مصادر العربيه ان اللقاء سريا في
الاردن برعايه الامريكيه يجمع قياده في
الجيش الليبي مع زعماء فصائل المسلحه في
طرابلس ووفق مصادر العربيه فان طائره خاصه
واجهتها العاصمه الاردنيه المصادر اضافه
ان بعض الشخصيات المقربه من التشكيلات
المسلحه خرجت عبر دفعه الى الاردن وبعضهم
غادر عن طريق تونس من اجل لقاء الشخصيات
الممثله للشرق الليبي خصوصا بعد تسليم
الاسرى في الفتره الماضيه
من جهه اخرى اعربت اللجنه الوطنيه لحقوق
الانسان في ليبيا عن ابتعاضها بسبب ما
قسمته احتكار المجلس الرئاسي لمشروع
المصالحه الوطنيه بعيدا عن المؤسسات
الحقوقيه والقانونيه واكدت اللجنه انه لا
يمكن تحقيق المصالحه الشامله والسلام في
ليبيا بالاقصاء والترميش وانما من خلال
مشاركه فاعله من جميع المكونات الاجتماعيه
والسياسيه وان تكون نتائج
حوار المجتمع جاد وحقيقيه
حضر رئيس المجلس الرئاسي الليبيه محمد
المنفي من ان تجاهل المصالح
والمصالحه وتقاسم السلطه سيزيد المشهد في
البلاد تعقيدا وقال ان حل الازمه يكمن في
المصالحه والممارسه الديمقراطيه في تسويه
الصراع
الحل لازمه هذا الوطن هو ليس في المحافظه
وليس في تقاسم الموارد والمال ولكنه في
الصدر وجبر الضرر والعفو والمصالحه انه في
استعاده روح الوحده الوطنيه الاخويه
والعيش المشترك في هذا الوطن المعطاه انه
في رجوء الرجوع الى حكمه الاجداد والاباء
المؤسسين والاحتكام الى قواعد العرف
والدين والممارسات السلميه والديمقراطيه
في تسويه الصراع ايها الساده ان كل الصيغ
المجربه في ليبيا لبناء السلطه بقت بالفشل
لانها تجاهلت الحل واحرقت المراحل
وقفزت على مطالب الشعب الليبي الى مطالب
التاسع
زار الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدنا الحدود
الامريكيه المكسيكيه في اول زياره الرسميه
له الى هذا البلد بعد اكثر من عامين من
توله منصبه ومن المنتظر ان يعقد ايضا في
العاصمه مكسيكو اليوم اجتماعات ثنائيه مع
نظيره المكسيكي قبل قمه النقل
الشماليه غدا الثلاثاء مع رئيس الوزراء
الكندي جاستن ترودو
اعلن الخميس الماضي
وعلى الحدود وتوسيع جنسيته اولئك الذين
طردهم الى المكسيك
شرعت اسرائيل بتنفيذ عقوباتنا على
الفلسطينيين بحجه توجههم الى المحاكم
الدوليه ضد اسرائيل وكانت اولي العقوبات
سحب البطاقه بطاقه الشخصيه الهامه من وزير
الخارجيه الفلسطيني رياض الملكي اثناء
مروره عبر معبر الكرامه الحدودي مع الاردن
بدات اسرائيل اليوم تنفيذ قرارات مجلس
الوزراء السياسي الامنيه الاسرائيلي
الكابنت بفرض عقوبات ضد السلطه الفلسطينيه
بحجه ان الفلسطينيين توجهوا الى محكمه
العدل الدوليه لطلب راي استشاري قانوني
حول المنظومه الاستعماريه الاسرائيليه
اثناء عوده معالي وزير الخارجيه
والمغتربين دكتور رياض المالكي ايه صباح
هذا اليوم الى ارض الوطن عائدا من
البرازيل تم سحب بطاقه ااه ما تسمى بطاقه
الفي اي بي وخضع لكافه الاجراءات التعسفيه
المعتمده عند الجانب الاسرائيلي على
المعبر
سحبوا بطاقات الشخصيات الهامه من كبار
القاده الفلسطينيين كان من بين سلسله من
العقوبات التي هددت بها اسرائيل
وتعالت الاصوات مطالبه بتنفيذها عقوبه
مشاركه قيادات في السلطه الفلسطينيه في
استقبال الاسير كريم يونس في مناطق الخط
الاخضر بعد قضاء اربعين عاما في السجون
الاسرائيليه
تعتقد بانه يمكن مع هذه الحكومه
يعني خلق شركات دوليه كبيره للضغط على هذه
الحكومه داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي هذه
الحكومه غير مقبوله عقوبات ماليه
واقتصاديه تحت رهن التنفيذ قررتها اسرائيل
للضغط على الفلسطينيين من اجل الامتناع عن
طرح قضيتهم امام المؤسسات الحقوقيه
الدوليه
العقوبات هذه المره قالت
القاده الفلسطينيين في محاوله لكبح جماح
التحرك الدبلوماسي الفلسطيني الهادي في
الى اعاده القضيه الفلسطينيه الى المؤسسات
الدوليه من جديد
من امام حاجز شمال رام الله خالد القاسم
العربيه
بعد ايام من طرح مذكره الامير هاري للبيع
تضمنت مزاعم جديده عن الخلاف والشقاق داخل
العائلات الملكه البريطانيه هذه يستعدوا
لوابل من المقابلات المثيره للجدل
في كل مره حاولت فيها القيام بذلك بخصوصيه
كانت هناك احاطات وتسريبات وخلق القصص ضد
زوجتي دراما ملكيه بامتياز بدات قبل سنوات
بطلها الامير البريطاني هاري وزوجته
الامريكيه مجانا هرب من قفص الملكيه بحثا
عن حريه الدعيان انهما سلبياتها ورغبه
منهما بالابتعاد عن الاضواء
الا ان ظهور الثنائي ميغان وهاري بات اكثر
مما كان عليه عندما كان تحتسق في قصر
باكينغهام احدها كان مع برنامج
كانت تدور معظمها حول كواليس حياتهما
السابقه
بتصريحات الناريه عزازه الفجوه بينهما
وبين العائله الملكيه البريطانيه التي
يزعم هاري بانهم استخدموا وسائل الاعلام
ضدهما
المثير للسخريه هنا هو طرح مذكرات الامير
هاري للبيع قبل الموعد الرسمي لنشرها
مذكرات تضمنت مزاعم جديده عن الخلاف
والشقاق داخل العائله الملكه البريطانيه
واتهامات وجهها الامير هاري لشقيقه ولي
العهد البريطاني واليمن بالتعدي الجسدي
عليه حسب ما نقلته صحيفه داكارديان عن
تسريبات الكتاب التي تقول ان الامير
واليمن امير ويلز وريث العرش وشقيقه هاري
الاكبر اوقع اخاه ارضا في شجار
كما ان هاري زعم ايضا ان شقيقه وليم تطاول
لفظيا على ميجا واصفا اياها بالصعبه
والوقحاء والمزيفه
الشهره التي اكتسبها هاري وميغن منذ ان
تخليا عن واجباتهما الملكيه في عام 2020
بدات ترتد عليهما بالعكس حسب استطلاعات
للراي فالكثير من البريطانيين ذاقوا ذرعا
بملو دراما العائله المالكيه برمتها وان
الكشف عن مزيد من المفاجات لن يغير ارائهم
سواء متعاطفه مع هاري وزوجته ميجان ماركل
او تلك المنتقدتها لهما
روان حمزه العربيه
بعد سنوات من الجفاف المحاصيل الزراعيه
باتت مهدده بعد تخلي الدوله عن سياسه الري
بسبب تراجع مخزون السدود الى الربع تقريبا
لونها الاخضر بدا يتحول تدريجيا الى
الاصفر بسبب الجفاف وقله الامطار هذه
زراعه مهدده بالانتصار كما يؤكد كمال
ويحيى الفلاحان بالجهه ليجد نفسه مع
عزيزين عن انقاذ زراعتهما الاول
لونها كان معناها تواصلت معناها نقص في
الامطار هذه الزراعه توصل معناها تعطي
المنتوج اللي همم
نتاملوا معنا
الامطار
الفاضله من الامطار
وسنوات واحنا نتكلم
في وزاره الشباب
الوضع هنا لا يختلف وكثيرا عن باقي مناطق
البلاد حيث يواجه اكثر من نصف مليون فلاح
تونسيه خطر ضياع عصابات هذا العام بسبب
الجفاف
الجفاف هو نقص الامطار يهددان الزرعه
والزرعه في تونس التي بات تحت خط الفقر
المائيه وصار فلاحوها في صراع دون اسلحه
مع وضعيه تاريخيه تعالت معها الاصوات
المناديه بضروره اعلان حاله الطوارئ
المناخيه في البلاد
وتاكد السلطات ان الوضع المائيه كارفي حيث
دخل تونس مرحله الفقر المائيه وتتجه
تدريجيا نحو العطش حيث لا تتجاوز سعه
السجود فيها 25% ولا حل الا في الاستغلال
عن ري المحاصيل وترشيد استعمال الماء في
باقي المجالات
نجوى بتقول كده بس برشا مع عدنان اليوم
الساعه في الاستعمال المنزلي في السياحه
في سيناء
على الاقل قطاع الفلاحي لانه روب ليش قطاع
فيه
امن وقوتنا الشعب التونسي
من الجفاف ازدادت حدتها مؤخرا مصدرها الى
تركيز اربع المحطات لتحليه مياه البحر
ومحاولات اعاده تاهيل منظومتها المائيه
وسدودها وليد عبدالله العربيه تونس
الى العناوين
عوده الهدوء تدريجيا في البرازيل الرئيس
الحاليه توعد المخربين ويتم سلفه والاخير
يتبرع
اطلاق نار على ايرانيين تجمعوا امام سجن
رجاء بكرك تمديدا بعزم النظام اعدام
متظاهرين
مصادر العربيه تكشف عن لقاء سريه في
الاردن برعايه الامريكيه بين قيادات في
الجيش الليبي والزعماء فصائل المسلحه
شكرا لكم القلقاكم بعد قليل
[موسيقى]